hello pi data global
my name is aileen nielsen and i am
presenting today
on open source fairness
just a little bit of background about me
i am a us training lawyer but i have
also worked as a data scientist at a
variety of startups
in several different fields and i now do
empirical and experimental research on
non-technology
including a lot of um empirical work and
experimental work thinking about how
humans and ai products will interact
and what that means when we think about
legal concepts um
broadly like fairness but more
concretely like redistribution
anti-discrimination administrative law
and these sorts of things
and i will also make a shameless plug
which is that i have a book called
practical fairness coming out from
o'reilly in december
i wrote this book for the same reason
i'm making this presentation which is
that i think we
need far more fairness tools than we
have and we need to make sure that
ordinary data scientists and machine
learning engineers
know about these tools and get them into
their just
normal toolkit because this is very much
something that needs to be happening
all the time but it is not yet here's an
outline of this very brief talk
i will first just try to convince you
that this is something that we need to
be worried about
i can imagine that at this point many
people are thinking okay
you know like ai fairness has been a
thing
like at least for five years especially
for the last three years is such a hot
topic
probably the problems are solved now so
firstly i want to say no they're not and
convince you of that and convince you
that you should care
secondly i want to think about defining
fairness right people talk about
fairness and machine learning
ai bias unfair impacts all the time but
i just want to get into that a little
bit more
it's a really complicated topic so i'm
not going to give you just
a definition of fairness that will solve
all your problems but i want to give you
an overview
of why defining fairness is even a
challenge and what that means for
practical work
thirdly i'm going to talk about specific
fairness interventions okay so i've
hopefully convinced you this is a
problem
um talked about how we can measure the
problem and now we're going to talk
about how we can intervene to make
better products to make the world a
better place because the products we are
releasing
are more fair than they would be without
these interventions
and finally uh true to the name of the
talk i want to give you an
overview of a few open source packages
are out that are out there that have
python interfaces that you can use
because it's easy to sort of think
broadly
what is ai fairness how do i get started
but it's another thing
to be able to say okay now i can go
download this package play with it and
potentially put it into
production even in my workplace or in my
personal projects or in my research and
so i hope you are able to do that at the
end of this talk
so new systems same old problems
we have all heard so much about
fairness and ai everybody cares about it
presumably everybody thinks this is a
good thing provided that their
particular
definition of fairness could be
implemented but in fact
there are still so many embarrassing
facts so i often think about this when
people say
um you know why do we need all this
pcness and all this affirmative action
and i'm not looking to get into debates
about that but i will
have the same response thereof have you
looked at the world have you looked at
the way the world
seems to work so as much as you think
you've heard too much about ai fairness
there continue to be problems with ai
fairness really major problems
so for example on the left i have a clip
where the housing department
was investigating facebook for a housing
discrimination
charge so it was alleged that facebook
was violating
housing rights fair housing rights
uh laws that have been on the books for
40 or 50 years so these are not new laws
they're old laws
these old laws say that you cannot
discriminate on the basis of race
or any other protected category when you
are offering housing
but in fact for about a decade facebook
was enabling just
this behavior because what facebook
allowed people to do is to target ads
including ads for housing to people
according to ethnic affinity
age religion gender all sorts of
categories that should be protected for
the purposes of housing discrimination
and i should note none of this was
proven in a court of law so i should
really be saying that all of these facts
are alleged
but of course many of them are also just
observable even to ordinary people so it
was quite observable
that the facebook advertising platform
gave you the ability
to advertise in a way that targeted
people based on protected categories
such as ethnicities such as family
status and so on
and that just clearly breaks federal law
on
fair housing allocation more recently um
the apple card was investigated and
publicly accused of gender
discrimination
after a computer programmer a fairly
famous one noticed that he and his wife
were treated quite
differently when they applied for apple
cards right so presumably
their financials were quite similar but
he noticed that his wife
got a much worse offer than he did and
again we can think
wow these are sophisticated parties this
was apple partnering with goldman sachs
they surely care about this right
because the fair credit
act is another act in the u.s that
requires fair access to credit such as
credit cards such as banking services
and says you cannot discriminate on the
basis of gender and yet that appear to
be what the algorithm was doing again we
can't know for
for sure what the ultimate finding of
fact would be in a court of law but we
can say that it appeared at least from
the media coverage like that might be a
possibility
so even though we've heard so much about
fairness still a problem
why is that well there are many reasons
for this one is the danger of
proxies so as recently as last october
just a year ago there was a big study in
science
and what these authors found over maya
at all was that a very large health
insurance company in the united states
had unintentionally built a racist
decision-making algorithm
the goal of the company had been to
identify
those people among their insured pool
who were most at risk of getting sick
with the thought of oh if we can
identify them for additional
interventions we might help them get
less sick
which is good they'll get less sick and
we will spend less money and so
everybody wins
the problem was that they used as a
proxy for seriousness of
illness uh health care spending
but unfortunately in the united states
it has historically been the case and
continues to be
that in general more money is spent on a
white patient than on a black patient
all as equal
and so when even this large
sophisticated company decided to use the
proxy of money sent
as an indicator of how it
unintentionally replicated
the disparity in spending um because of
the use of the proxy and so this just
shows that even well-intentioned actors
who seemingly should have the right
economic incentive they were trying to
identify
anyone of any race who was likely to get
sick
can unintentionally build some very
racist products
what is this there are other reasons too
incompleteness of data sets right this
is one of the reasons people
use proxies why do they use proxies for
seriousness of health condition
because it isn't necessarily that easy
from the mass that we have from
electronic healthcare records
to determine who is really seriously ill
and who isn't so perhaps to them
on first impression it seemed like oh
perhaps money spent could be a very good
objective metric for how sick someone is
but in fact what that was was an
incomplete data set there simply wasn't
perhaps enough data to identify who was
really
sick there are also other forms of
incomplete data sets and sometimes the
incompleteness of the data set is itself
a problem
so for example we only record successes
in our data sets where we have provided
the opportunity to succeed so if we're
thinking
again about a financial example like the
apple card perhaps
when apple or goldman sachs was trying
to model who was a good risk and who
wasn't they were using
existing data sets but those data sets
were built
based on existing decisions so for
example
imagine that if you successfully repay a
loan and that's considered the success
you are marked as a one where one is the
positive and zero is the negative label
individuals can't repay loans if they
aren't
given loans right so for the people for
whom you are not granting the
opportunity
you systematically do not have those
people in your data set
to find out if you were even correct to
deny them the opportunity right that is
a systematic
incompleteness of your data set because
you're not doing a randomized controlled
study rather you're making decisions
and then potentially learning from your
own decisions but in the long term that
is just going to reinforce certain
systematic
unfairness if there is unfairness in the
underlying system
so in other similar cases individuals
can't graduate from a university
if they aren't admitted to the
university right so sometimes when we're
making assumptions or building models
about who is likely to succeed
we need to think about whether we have
even observed the counter factual
because if we haven't
we're not really giving our model the
full space of possibilities as we assume
we are
relatedly but a different problem is
that sometimes a label
means different things for different
groups so in addition to just not giving
certain groups
access to certain possibilities so that
we can observe those counter factuals
we can also have the possibility that we
have
a data set with different kinds of
people and those people
are actually treated differently or the
process for labeling them is a little
bit different
even though that's not apparent from the
data set so perhaps police officers
selectively cut
cut people a break with unintentional
racial patterns i'm a police officer i
think i give everyone a fair shake but
perhaps i have some kind of implicit
bias so that i'm more
likely to be lenient with someone of my
own race than of
other people in which case my labeling
of people as either criminal or not
will itself have some kind of systematic
bias
and labels are even greater than that so
i just talked about how the label can
mean different things
labeling itself also is a problem
to quote judge eastern brook a very
famous u.s judge
depictions of subordination tend to
perpetuate
subordination right so even if
labels are correct and who says they're
correct anyway
the labeling can have damaging effects
so for example i performed this google
search
in april 2020 unprofessional hairstyles
for work
what's really interesting here is that
all the hairstyles or almost all of them
are for women so this already seems to
imply that only
women commit this egregious breach of
having unprofessional hairstyles for
work
and what you also probably notice is
there are quite a few
black women relatives to white women in
these pictures right whereas if i had
googled something else i might not quite
see the same racial balance
in fact this has been written in the
past at one point it was only
black women or black people appearing in
these google search results so you can
say it's gotten more fair
and that the label now seems to
recognize that many races can be guilty
of inappropriate
pair but we don't seem to have fixed the
gender problem that at least right now
um if i'm a child learning about the
world by searching google or if i'm even
just an
impressionable adult as we all are
whether we recognize it or not
um google is teaching me that only women
can have
unprofessional hairstyles um so putting
in this label itself is harmful and
sometimes you want to question the label
and say why do we even have an
unprofessional hairstyle label
it's one thing to say you have an unsafe
hairstyle perhaps you work at a
construction site and you know something
like a ponytail might not be safe
but why unprofessional is that just a
label that is itself used as a form of
subordination
um and like i said these uh these
results are fairly
uh shocking it gets even worse even when
i
added men to the start of the search
they still return a lot of images about
women so again i'm getting a very strong
message here that it's women who are the
problem with the unprofessional
hairstyles
more problems with labels some of these
are related to how humans behave so in
speech humans often prioritize labeling
unusual or non-standard elements of a
photo
so if i see a male surgeon i might just
say there's a surgeon but if i see a
female surgeon i'm going to say oh
there's a female surgeon i'm sort of
highlighting what i
view to be statistically unusual
so what that means is that our labels
again are systematically different for
different groups because of cultural or
cognitive reasons rather than
for reasons that are truly related to
information
there's an essentializing tendency of
machine learning a bit like there's an
essentializing tendency even of how
we describe the world so i just said i
would you know
um often people if they see a male
surgeon will say surgeon
and for female surgeon female surgeon um
this is already some kind of
essentialization that even humans do
right if we see that most surgeons are
men then we're sort of like oh surgeon
i'm gonna sort of it's just sort of a
man
and otherwise that's not the norm
machine learning models do the exact
same
thing they sort of essentialize things
so if you take a slightly biased data
set
train it with a logistic regression or
many other models you'll often get an
even more biased data set so it's not
just that machine learning models
replicate bias
they tend to exacerbate it so for
example in this graphic i have taken
from the washington post researchers
looked at the disparity between
actual um
share of um men versus women in the
labor force versus what appeared from
the google image search
and so for example what they found was
google image search seemed to
hide in the disparity between
representativeness of men and women that
is whatever the disparity might be
in the underlying profession google
image search and whatever machine
learning algorithm is powering it
heightens that disparity so as we have a
world that's increasingly
shaping our inputs by via some kind of
machine learning algorithm we are
already taking our own essentializing
tendencies and now we are going to have
those amplified by machine learning
tendencies that do the exact same thing
another problem uh we have this focus on
kpis right we tend to be obsessed with
accuracy and think that we can't
sacrifice accuracy for anything
here's some good news though one of the
reasons you should be open to fairness
interventions it turns out that you can
often
reduce measures of unfairness without
sacrificing much accuracy so this is
actually uh from some findings in 2011
almost 10 years ago and already they
were finding that you could for example
minimally impact
accuracy while substantially impacting a
measure of discrimination and it has
only gotten better
since then so you should also be aware
that in addition to fairness being a
real
and pervasive problem even in 2020
um many interventions that you can do
that are quite effective will have
minimal cost to your bottom line
you also want to be aware that high
dimensional data sets are going to have
dangerous correlation
so another problem with machine learning
is we sort of celebrate
unidentified patterns we need to be
aware that some identity
unidentified patterns are actually
incredibly problematic and
the classic case of this is anything to
do with zip code or geographic area that
tends to be highly correlated with race
so for example the practice of redlining
in which in the past banks would say oh
we're just not going to lend to that zip
code
that was in fact often a way to be a
proxy for race and so when banks were
saying we're not lending to that zip
code what they meant
really was we're not lending to black
communities and so you want to make sure
your algorithm is not doing something
like that
blindness does not produce fairness so
just like having a very wide data set is
not going to protect you
um getting rid of problematic attributes
is not going to protect you because it's
possible
that even unintentionally you are
treating people differently
through your machine learning algorithm
even if you are not explicitly measuring
their race or their religion or their
gender or any other protected attribute
finally by definition minorities are
less attended to by machine learning
learning algorithms so whenever you use
a machine learning algorithm
out of the box without some way of
acknowledging this you know by
definition that minority
groups will likely have higher error
rates of some kind
unless they just happen to be very much
like whatever the majority group is
this is by definition you have less
training data so your loss function is
going to weigh those losses less
okay and here's just a graphic example
of this that i have borrowed with
permission from professor aaron roth
so you can see how this group
which is the numerical minority is not
going to be well served by a model
trained on the majority
and that's quite unfortunate okay on to
our next topic defining fairness
really difficult to do as it turns out
there are sort of
major classes of fairness definitions
one is demographic parody
that basically says we think um
all groups that are sort of meaningful
groups to define such as gender or
race or what have you we think those are
those
metrics should produce equal outcomes
you know blacks and whites should have
equal outcomes men and women should have
equal outcomes
that doesn't mean every individual but
it means approximately the same success
or failure
rights counter factual fairness
this is where we say well since we think
something like
race shouldn't matter the way we'll
assess fairness is to change
race or the gender or what have you
while holding all else equal
and the less the output changes the more
fair the fairer the system is
this is okay definition wise it can be
difficult to
test and practice and so finally we have
this thing called equality of odds
this is a bit like demographic parity
but instead of saying that the success
rates for all groups should be the same
the authors narrow in and say no it's
more
that um the probability of the false
positive
and true positive rates for individuals
who have a true positive
rating should be equal so of the
individuals who deserve the opportunity
of that subset of the population the
proportion of individuals
getting the opportunity should be the
same and that's why it's called equality
of
odds or sometimes when it's more
narrowly defined equality of opportunity
this is a little bit different from
demographic parity because it enforces
the parity only at the level of a
sub-group the successful individuals
that is the individuals who should be
successful we look at their rates rather
than the whole population rate
these are just some classes of
definitions there are literally
dozens of definitions of fairness there
are
fairness and consistencies though
different group-oriented definitions of
fairness can be inconsistent
in the sense that you can't equalize
them at the same time so in many systems
you can't have
the same false positive and false
negative rates
say for different racial groups or
gender groups at the same time
if you equalize the false positive rate
then the false negative rate won't be
the same if you equalize the false
negative rate then the false positive
rate won't be the same
um likewise group oriented definitions
of fairness can come into conflict with
individual levels of fairness so you
might say well i want
uh the success rates for men and women
to be about the same
but also say to enhance individual
fairness that when i look at an
applicant
and the only thing i change is male
versus female that those should be very
consistent results
it turns out again mathematically it's
hard to get all of that at the same time
to have those group-wide fairness
metrics and the individual fairness
metrics looks the same
i won't go into this there is a number
of publications as to why this
is i recommend kula kova's paper on this
in 2016 merely because it is very
accessible you can work through with
simple algebra
and you can see that it's necessarily
true that there are some
tensions that if you have fairness
definition a fulfilled you might not be
able to have fairness definition be
fulfilled
for example you can't have the same
number of false positives
and false negatives per racial group
when you're thinking about
criminal recidivism modeling and it
turns out that the reason for that is
that if the underlying base rates for
different populations are different
then you cannot match their error rates
that is simply a mathematical certainty
for these sorts of models
so this is more of that math i would
encourage you to look at it in the paper
also so that's sort of one complication
with fairness metrics is there are so
many ways to define fairness
and they contradict one another and so
far actually when i've been saying
fairness what i have really meant is
anti-discrimination right is thinking
about the fact that we don't want people
treated differently
simply because they belong to some
category but there are other values
implicit in fairness that i'm not
addressing today but you want to think
about
values like consent as far as those
relate to
data privacy issues values like the
material rewards for production and
distribution of information so people
talk about
data labor why is it that all of the
value produced from the big data economy
is just going to
digital entities what about the people
like you and me who are observed
um and our data has some value and why
don't we receive that so you can think
about this
sort of distribution element of fairness
privacy and security right there are all
sorts of security problems and privacy
problems with machine learning models
right now
this is tremendously difficult and
complicated to get right but
unfortunately most data scientists don't
even try
that is we know that there are
adversarial attacks that there are
privacy attacks that sometimes if you're
clever
you can extract training data from the
model itself right so we know that
perhaps the data itself is under attack
through the models
that's also about fairness because if
people have provided their data
with consent for a model to be trained
that doesn't mean they have provided
consent to
to face these other privacy and security
issues
there's also autonomy um often we're
using machine learning to
undermine autonomy we're trying to build
distracting products addictive products
products with
so-called dark patterns where we exploit
cognitive biases
to defeat what people want we say oh you
wanted to buy
x how about by x and y and we have sort
of clever models to predict when people
will be vulnerable
that doesn't sound very fair either so
those are other fairness
considerations that don't get talked
enough don't
don't get talked about enough but that
you should be thinking about too
so i'm focusing on anti-discrimination
but there are other fairness elements
and they have other metrics okay so now
we talk about fairness intervention so
hopefully i've convinced you
that the specific fairness problem of
anti-discrimination is a problem
i have recognized that there are many
ways to define anti-discrimination but
i've also explained to you that
sometimes those definitions are in
tension
because many definitions can seem
compelling but i can't satisfy them at
the same time
i can't make everything perfect at the
same time now i want to talk about well
you want to do something about fairness
how long would you do that
here's sort of wolfram's version of the
data science pipeline and i want to
think about how we intervene around here
and my point to you is that at every
point along this stage
there are fairness questions we can be
asking from the very formulation of the
question
to how we clean and explore the data to
how we build the model and validate it
to how we decide to deploy that model
so fairness interventions by pipeline
stage
if you think about the purpose why are
you even building a model
are you building a model to target a
vulnerable population or are you
building a model to empower a vulnerable
population
that's already a fairness issue thinking
about the data you select are you sure
with the data you're selecting that
you're selecting it for the right reason
that you're sure it has good quality
that you can check whether there were
systematic biases remember all the
problems i highlighted at the beginning
of the talk
they almost all fall into data selection
how are you choosing a proxy if you're
choosing a proxy how do you know that
proxy won't introduce additional bias
and so on
then there are these three phases
pre-processing in processing and
post-processing
these refer to ways in which you
actually change your data
to make it have a less discriminatory
outcome
according to whatever fairness metric
you choose so it can be a group fairness
metric like
i think groups different groups should
have the same error statistics
it can be an individual metric like i
want highly consistent decisions where
if all i do is change the race of an
individual i get the same outcome and
that's what i really care about
these sorts of metrics but you can use
them for pre-processing to sort of
modify the way you represent your data
you can use them for in-processing where
you
train with a loss function that is
sensitive to fairness
or post-processing where once you
identify labels
you might change them to enhance the
fairness of the outputs
there's also performance monitoring and
stress testing after your product is
entirely finished
and black box auditing so some
pre-processing examples
sometimes what you might want to do is
do something like randomly flip
sensitive attribute labels to remove
whatever information might be correlated
with those sensitive attributes
you can re-weight data points to remove
disparate impact you can say i am going
to make this data set
look as though there is no difference in
population a versus population b and the
way you might do that is
for the underprivileged population
operate their successful individuals and
for the
overly privileged population downgrade
their successful individuals and bring
about parity that way
you can also think about ways to
represent the space for the input data
that will balance the
disparate impact fairness metric so
here's some recommended reading in this
area
then there's in processing and
processing usually relates to modifying
your loss function
with some kind of discrimination penalty
so in addition to an incorrectness of
label penalty you can have a
discrimination penalty
and that can work with any of those
fairness metrics we've talked about
you can also use adversarial learning
patterns where an adversary tries to
learn the membership
of for example a sensitive attribute
like race while the model tries to learn
an outcome
so you try to build a model that both
gets the outcome right but also provides
as little information as possible about
the sensitive attribute
and so here are two papers i'd recommend
that develop methodologies to do that
and then post-processing post-processing
is when you take a
score and you know that the system
producing the score
is still resulting in some kind of
discrimination depending on what metric
you are using for discrimination
and then you either randomize the labels
perhaps the labels close to the decision
boundary and you say well discrimination
is probably happening close to the
discrimination
boundary so right around here i'm going
to randomize the labels
perhaps of the underprivileged group or
the over-privileged group
or both to try to introduce a little
more noise and a little less
discrimination
into the outputs of my model you can
also do this in a way where you equalize
along some cost function so if you
recognize that certain
kinds of mistakes are more or less
costly
that is another way you can deal with
this so that's post-processing
and then of course you have auditing in
this case you choose a fairness metric
and compute
these as appropriate or you measure and
report the influence of input variables
these are two tactics people take for
auditing
okay so now that we've done a whirlwind
of fairness interventions
concrete ways that you can action take
action
to make your products safer and fairer
and more reflective of the world as you
would like it to be
how do you build these well here's some
open soft source software
all of these packages are quite easy to
use and well documented
so i'm just going to give you an
overview aif 360 is a project from ibm
they offer pre-processing in processing
and post-processing options which are
quite handily broken down here
they also have commonly used data sets
so there are certain data
sets you see in the fairness community a
lot such as the german credit data set
the compass data set the adult income
data set
which is u.s adult income those are all
in
there quite a large array of fairness
metrics are built
in and what's really nice about this
data set
or code base rather is that they
implement many cutting-edge published
algorithms so unfortunately academics
do not always contribute to one standard
code base often they will just release
the code for their
paper in their own github repository so
you don't
usually have a way of using many
state-of-the-art algorithms in just one
package but that is what aif 360 does
and that's quite nice because of the
sponsorship of ibm
and the fact that it's quite up to date
and just to show you how easy the
example code is to use you can see
here's an example
of a pre-processing tactic so you
pre-process
you train and then you can already
compute a metric just in a few lines
so the struggle here is knowing what
these metrics mean and knowing what
these techniques are
you have to have a conceptual basis to
use them but once you do
the code is already written for you
another example of the iqtas project so
this is out of the center for data
science and public policy at uchicago
although i believe they've moved to
carnegie mellon uh but this
product rather than being about fairness
interventions is about fairness auditing
and they give you either
a web interface a command line interface
or a python library
they have an extensive implementation of
fairness metrics and what they allow you
to do
are reports like this where you will get
a breakdown of the um
the bias they'll tell you sort of what
performance metrics they used what bias
metrics they considered what
groups they considered as far as
sensitive attributes and you will get
visual representations of the bias in
your model so this can be a way to set
up a nice automatic
uh check for bias they also include a
python library so if you want to do your
own coding you can do that as well and i
show you here
just how simple it is and again you get
these automatic representations
so so far i've told you sort of how you
can actively
intervene in your process with aif360
and then iq test is one tool where you
can automate the auditing
here's another one fairml it's a little
bit different iqtas tends to look at
fairness metrics and how they vary by
group
fairml instead looks at feature
importance so they sort of look at the
inputs rather than the output so how are
these
inputs affecting my outputs and seeing
if some of the inputs seem to matter
more than they should
so for example one one example they
provide and again
very easy to use interface um is that if
you look
at i believe this is the compass
algorithm a very famous one they find
that african-american seems to matter a
whole lot but of course it probably
shouldn't right so something like this
showing that an input that shouldn't
matter is in fact highly influential to
the outputs of a model
is another way to look for fairness
problems i notice this
addresses both explainability and
anti-discrimination
and finally there's the ml fairness gym
this comes out of google although it is
unofficial so google will not
necessarily maintain it but what they
introduce is this dynamic rather than
static notion of fairness they
say you can't just look how your model
is doing now what you probably want to
do is simulate
what are the effects of deploying your
model because once you put your model
into effect it produces an action which
in turn influences the environment
but the environment that your algorithm
has acted on
now produces an observation which you
might use for learning
and so they recognize that this care
there could be a cycle where the
algorithm
is both influencing the world but then
influencing itself because it will
continue collecting data
and you can think in this way how might
i have these sort of feedback loops
where i might have runaway bias or
runaway unfairness
or also how can i just think dynamically
about how my model is going to impact
the world
and so what they do is they give you a
simulation environment you think about
sort of fairness metrics you want to use
you think about what kind of agent you
want to use and they have coded up quite
a few
so you can think about college
admissions or classifiers or
allocators and then they let you play
that out over time and they say
okay in this case this is sort of
over time what things are going to look
like so maybe over time things get more
fair or less
fair or distribution gets better or
worse but this is something that has
also been missing from the fairness
literature and is quite useful so that's
another take
um so just to give you an overview after
six of
these state-of-the-art um
state-of-the-art cutting-edge ways to
modify
your training processes or your training
data to enhance fairness
iqritos and fair ml will help you audit
a model
including a black box model and then the
ml fairness gym will help you think
about the dynamic
temporally sensitive aspects of fairness
thinking about how fairness
has to reflect an evolving environment
and shouldn't just be a static view of
your algorithm
so thank you for your time and i look
forward to meeting you at the q a
sessions